chic la vie med spa the sponsors of this
next segment want to help you reach your
skin rejuvenation goals and here is how
hi everybody my name is susana i am the
spa manager here at chic living med spa
and what's unique about this practice is
we have a number of treatments in the
spa for skin rejuvenation and also
maintaining the results that are
achieved through some of our surgical
procedures with dr smith and dr malcolm
paul one of the most common procedures
that we do here at chiclevi med spa is a
procedure called fraxel fraxel dual
specifically what's unique about fraxel
in fraxel dual is that it has two
wavelengths and we use those different
wavelengths to target something specific
either deep within the skin such as a
post-surgical scar or perhaps any trauma
to the skin including either superficial
or deep acne scars and we also use a
wavelength that's a little bit more
superficial and that really targets
pigmentation they call it the magic
eraser when we combine those two
technologies or those two wavelengths
together that is known as fraxel dual
and our results are even exacerbated
when i meet with our patients and they
want to know how many treatments they'll
need to achieve an optimal result i
basically tell them whatever is going to
make you happy when you look in the
mirror
so it may take a number or a series of
treatments to get those scars either
surgical acneic even stretch marks
smoothed out but there is a tangible
difference each time we use fraxel so
fraxel is excellent for reducing fine
lines and for producing collagen and yes
you absolutely will get a suppleness to
your skin however if you're looking for
lifting and toning and tightening then
we have to turn you on to all therapy it
is the only fda approved non-invasive
non-surgical device that actually lifts
the neck
the submental the lower face and even
the brow oh therapy produces a collagen
and elastin response
so basically what we do is we employ
that micro focused
energy
to an area of the skin called the smash
placing our energy right on top of the
smash ensures that the energy
is
creating that collagen and elastin so
you get the optimal result my patients
typically see a radiance in their skin
because that collagen is produced so
that radiance
is immediate
in about three weeks time you will start
to see a tangible difference in your
skin but the lifting and the toning and
the tightening is a three to six month
process
ultherapy is unique and that it lasts 18
to 24 months
so there is significant improvement over
time
many of our patients do combine
ultherapy with perhaps sculptra or an
injectable from one of our injectors or
they come back for a touch-up treatment
about you know a year later so that they
continue to produce that collagen and
elastin and keep their skin
tightened and toned
yes please thank you chiclet b med spot
for sponsoring this segment for more
information just call
702-233-8535 or head to
smithsurgery.com jc